علنت حركه حماس التوصل الى اتفاق على هدنه
انسانيه لم صمتت اصوات المدافع والقنابل
في غزه وتعطلت اله الموت الاسرائيليه لاول
مره بعد 50 يوما من حرب الاباده واحنا
والله بدنا هدن تامه مش كل يوم يقولنا
هدنه
وبكره اخترقوا الهدنه انها ايام
[موسيقى]
الهدنه
الله اكبر ولله الحمد الله اكبر ولله
الحمد خرج اكثر من 220 طفلا وسيده
فلسطينيه من سجون الاحتلال مقابل الافراج
عن نحو 80 من الاطفال والنساء
الاسرائيليين والاجانب المحتجزين لدى
المقاومه عادت الحياه جزئيا الى الاحياء
الشماليه في القطاع وانتعشت بعض الاسواق
في الجنوب وبدا الدفاع المدني بمهمه البحث
عن 7000 مفق تحت الانقاض دبابات بتقدم ومع
انه يفترض ان يكون هذا الاسبوع بلا ضحايا
انتهكت اسرائيل الاتفاق اكثر من مره وقتلت
مزارعا واصابت اخرين في اثناء عملهم شرق
مخيم المغازي في ثالث ايام الهدنه وفي
اليوم نفسه اصيب سبعه فلسطينيين برصاص
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في محيط مستشفيي
القدس والاندونيسي ومددت اسرائيل اعتقال
مدير مستشفى الشفاء في قطاع غزه محمد ابو
سلميه 45 يوما بزعم وجود ادله تثبت علمه
بوجود مقر لحركه حماس في المستشفى وقد
انتهى الامر باعتقال عدد من الطواقم
الطبيه وعلى راسهم مدير عام مجمع الشفاء
الطبي الدكتور محمد ابو سلميه ورغم
الخروقات الاسرائيليه للهدنه يبدو انها
نجحت في تهيئه الاجواء لابرام اتفاق هدنه
طويل مدى او حتى وقف اطلاق النار حسب ما
ذكرت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه الرسميه مؤكده
ان الدوحه تضيف مباحثات حول هذا الملف بين
الاستخبارات الامريكيه والمصريه
والاسرائيليه بمشاركه رئيس الوزراء القطري
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني وقبل
هذه المباحثات تشير الاجواء الدوليه الى
ميل اسرائيل الى هذه الهدنه مع انها تمثل
انتصارا لحركه حماس وفقا لكثير من خبراء
والساسه الغربيين ومنهم مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي السابق جون بولتن وقف
اطلاق النار المحتمل قد يدفع ثمنه الاكبر
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
اذ يهدده شركاه في الائتلاف الحكومي وعلى
راسهم وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن غفير
بالانسحاب من الحكومه اذا لم يعاود القتال
لكن الفاتوره الثقيله التي تدفعها اسرائيل
في هذه الحرب تضيق الخيارات امامنا
ف خسائر الاحتلال الاقتصاديه وصلت الى 48
مليار دولار وفق تقييم لشركه ليدر كيتال
ماركت للاستشارات الماليه في اسرائيل اما
الخسائر البشريه فيعترف رئيس جمعيه
المعاقين في جيش الاحتلال عيدان كلمن ان
1600 جندي اصيبوا باقات منذ السابع من
اكتوبر ويتسبب طول امد الحرب بتقليص الدعم
الدولي وخاصه الامريكي لتل ابيب الذي
يرفضه 70% من الشباب الامريكي الذين
تتراوح اعمارهم بين 18 و34 عاما وفق
استطلاع لشبكه ان بي سي نيوز الامريكيه
وعلى الجانب الاخر تؤكد صحيفه واشنطن بوست
ان الحرب على غزه تعقد جهود واشنطن لتوسيع
نطاق التطبيع مع
اسرائيل سلم على رسول الله يا
باسم سلم على رسول الله والي هيت فلسطين
بدها زلام بدها دم ترتو بالدم مشان ترجع
باذن الله غابت هذه المشاهد المؤلمه عن
غزه وانتقلت الى الضفه الغربيه المحتله
هذه دماء الطفل باسل ابو الوفاء الذي
قتلته قوات الاحتلال قنص بالرصاص مع طفل
اخر بعد اقتحام مخيم جنين ووصفت حركه حماس
اعدام الطفلين بالجريمه المروعه ودعت الى
ادانتها ومحاسبه قاده الاحتلال عليها في
المحاكم الدوليه واحد بقى هنا بك يصور
اجوا كنسو تخوا عليه اربع رصاص طخ عليه
اربع رصاصات اثنتين اجن فيه وثنتين ماجن
فيه وده اجت بولده هون صغير واستشهد الله
يرحمهم ومنذ بدء الهدنه اعتقلت قوات
الاحتلال 260 فلسطينيا في سلسله اقتحامات
متصاعده في الضفه الغربيه وتقول مصادر
فلسطينيه ان الحمله الاسرائيليه غير
مسبوقه اذ حاصرت القوات المتوغلة
سيارات الاسعاف الى المصابين واعلنت
المدينه منطقه عسكريه مغلقه بعد مواجهات
ليليه طويله خاضتها مع كتيبه جنين التي
تتبع لسرايا القدس ياتي هذا بعد ان اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي اغتيال قائدين بارزين في
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الضفه هما محمد
الزبيدي ووسام حنون في عمليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه استهدفته في جنين ويعد التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الاكثر عنفا منذ عقود
بحسب تقارير حقوقيه ويؤكد المكتب الوطني
للدفاع عن الارض ومقاومه الاستيطان ان
التجمعات البدويه في الضفه تتعرض لعمليات
هدم للبيوت والمنشات وتحرم من حق الحصول
على الكهرباء او الوصول الى مصادر المياه
ليضطر الاهالي الى الرحيل وبلغ عدد الاسر
المهجره في الضفه خلال الفتره الاخيره
151 اسره تضم اكثر من الف فرد ثلثهم اطفال
وفق منظمه ب سلم الاسرائيليه بال 2013 راح
ابن عمه
مجد بال 2021 22
راح ابن عمه براء وهي ابني بهاء
وبهاء نحمد الله طلب شهاده ونالها بعزه
وكرامه l